quick turn around for everybody but
especially the
youngster vard dropping it back off too
now vard with a shot Same by Mark coming
around with the he
scores his first National Hockey League
goal
well the incredible quickness of Conor
Bard to be able to wrap this Puck around
and get it in behind the net but how
about the play entering the Zone here
little pitch and catch with Ryan Donado
he takes a shot not from a great angle
but look at the net fromont Presence by
all and Donado and then Bard gets his
first of his National Hockey League
career and there's that quickness p and
that headiness of knowing where to get
that puck to the net